US military is helping in the search for
Argentina's lost submarine with 44
people aboard 10 airplanes and 11 ships
from several countries are scouring the
South Atlantic the San Juan vanished
Wednesday on the way from a port in the
extreme south of Argentina to a naval
base at Mar del Plata David Martin is at
the Pentagon with possible clues David
good morning good morning
search-and-rescue teams will be on the
lookout for any debris on the surface
and will monitor sonar signals for any
man-made sounds coming from below no one
knows what happened to the sub everyone
knows they have to find it as soon as
possible the Argentine submarine San
Juan has a crew of 44 including the
country's first female sub officer on
Sunday a British ice patrol ship
equipped with sub hunting sonar reached
the search area but tweeted that bad
weather was causing complications
several ships assigned to the search
effort had to spend the weekend in Port
rather than brave waves up to 26 feet
and winds up to 45 miles per hour heavy
seas did not stop aerial search efforts
including to u.s. maritime patrol planes
helping with the search in California
the Navy loaded submarine rescue
equipment aboard transport planes bound
for Argentina
an unmanned underwater vehicles were
sent from Hawaii to scan the seafloor
you're trying to gather all the data all
the information you can as quickly as
you can retired Navy captain Greg
Baumann was once the supervisor for the
Navy salvage and diving that ocean turns
out to be a very large ocean if you're
looking in the wrong box the San Juan
was last heard from on Wednesday when it
was midway in a 10-day transit from the
southern tip of Argentina to its
homeport
just south of Buenos Aires the San Juan
is powered by a combination of electric
and diesel power and according to the
Navy spokesman has enough food water and
power to last two weeks if in fact the
submarine is distressed and it submerged
and has a inability to surface it's a
race against time
if the submarine is underwater a rescue
chamber can latch on to the outside of
it and take the
Kru off in small groups but first they
have to find it Gail yes everybody's
hoping they do find it thank you very
much David